[Musica]
[Applauso]
a
quanto ci è mancato tutto questo
naturalmente non mi riferisco a sferrare
il morso a un pezzo di focaccia
per chi si occupa di ristorazione comune
alludo alla bellezza del convivio a
quella piacevolezza e la condivisione a
tavola
una boccata d'aria fresca che in qualche
modo ci stata stampata durante questa
pandemia e che io personalmente ho
riconquistato aggrappandomi ha due
passioni viscerali quello della musica e
quello per il cibo ed è andata quello
che sto per raccontarvi
intatta corde emotive tanto elementari 4
intime perché se ci pensiamo sono
veramente pochi momenti in cui
abbassiamo le difese si fa lanciammo la
bocca e lasciamo entrare degli agenti
esterni per darci beneficio espirare
mangiare bere scambiarci effusioni
se scaviamo un po più a fondo però
scopriamo che avg un legame chimico
molto più stretto tra questi automatismi
quotidiani
l'ossigeno in effetti a un nutriente e
fondamentale per il corpo umano è il
terzo elemento chimico che entra in
contatto con il nostro organismo dopo li
dà ragione al carbonio è fondamentale
per produrre energia cellulare e tutto
il metabolismo corporeo ruota intorno
all'asse cenno che noi in aria mo
respirando e ci viene trasportato
alimentando le cellule che in ogni
momento della nostra vita sì proprio
quando a cremoni stavo mangiando
possiamo quindi dire che noi ci aiutiamo
la prassi geno pensate che per bruciare
un solo grammo di grasso
dobbiamo prenderli e 2 litri
questo processo
chimico ha una funzione quello di
produrre la tutti ora una formula magica
l'atp è il nostro
mattoncino energetico
praticamente la molecola che consente di
attivare quasi ogni processo cellulare
contrarre i muscoli qualche caso un po
pochi
produrre energia bioelettrica per far
funzionare il nostro sistema nervoso
centrale o anche semplicemente mantenere
stabile la nostra temperatura corporea
sopra i 36 gradi centigradi
quando il volume di ossigeno e scarico
abbiamo un deciderà detto organico
invitiamo prematuramente addirittura se
in cambiamo della famosa anzi calci nota
i mussi a ovvero un debito con lunga di
ossigeno e nostra pietà bullismo
dall'enpa abbiamo gli aumenti di
stanchezza e possiamo anche compere
invitare i casi di obesità viscerale
tutto questo per dirvi che il modo in
cui un e respiriamo anche mentre
mangiava e funzionale per stare meglio e
anche per semplici in forma è una
meccanica esistenziale alla quale io ho
aggiunto un altro agente sensoriale per
milano benessere mio
qualche modo intercettare quella ripresa
d'aria che sentivo veramente non cambi
durante loeb dow lo spettro di tivo
anche in questo caso non mi strumentato
nulla di nuovo dal simposio di platone
passando per i banchetti romani
medievali
la musica ha sempre interpretato un
ingrediente quasi portanza all'interno
del vasto pensate che viene 1733 un
compositore tedesco e nome gara i fili
di te le vai cognola cosiddetta fermi
musique un'opera che realtà cercava di
scandire le varie fasi del pasto ognuna
con un attinente composizione
strumentale
facciamo poi un salto ai giorni nostri
di uno studio del 2014
dell'università dell'arkansas
ci conferma che il volume e il genere
della musica che ci fa su nelle orecchie
può influenzare drasticamente le nostre
scelte alimentari dal jazz al rock
all'hip hop insomma quello che noi
ascoltiamo ci condiziona secondo stiamo
facendo la spesa al supermercato se
quando stiamo ordinando un piatto
ristoranti
tutto questo poi viene enfatizzato se va
a toccare dei connotati emotivi legati
in qualche modo dello studio dhabi
sfavillare non si ferma qui pensate che
il secondo luca college dell'università
della florida anche la frequenza è
importante se noi ascoltiamo qualcosa
che rientrino nell'arco dei 55 decibel
siamo più propensi a cercare c pisana
che ci fanno bene se invece questa
soglia si impenna anche super e 70
decibel con le mogli ormeggi e siamo qui
a tratti da cpp e criminosi
ed equilibrati
in tutto questo se non davanti charles
burns è un professore dell'università di
oxford afferma che la musica è in grado
di amplificare drasticamente il gusto di
cibo e bevande
questo fenomeno secondo lui è stato
ribattezzato sony seasoning è
praticamente i primi esprimenti vennero
condotti nel 2011 in un ristorante in un
tre stelle michelin ed esaltati in
inghilterra insieme al virtuoso chef
heston blumenthal
iman siam
l'eccentrico gelato in questo di bacon e
uova gli assaggiatori di pane
tracciatori cambiava di volta in volta
la percezione di uno della uil
ingrediente a seconda della musica che
viene in passato in sottofondo
secondo spense infatti le nostre reti
che dialogano con le nostre famiglie
e l'uomo tende ad associare a un
determinato suono un determinato gusto
che sanno poi una corrispondenza che di
influenza la lettura del tempo non solo
questo ai suoni acuti tendiamo ad
associare favori molto agili ai suoni
più morbidi delicati la dolcezza o
quelle stabilità contro patti
accogliente in qualche modo ai suoni più
cupi e più profondi invece associamo una
mano o il famoso quinto gusto l'umano
molto caro agli amici di pony c
io personalmente nella mia ricerca del
mio tentativo di creare due un rito
della musica e cibo mi sono mosso su
corde e decisamente più emotive che
tecniche questo perché perché volevo
lasciare la possibilità a chiunque di
immedesimarsi di immergersi in questo
veri che sensoriale che va a scandire un
po alla vita di ognuno di noi quasi un
lasciapassare per il che avrebbero un
viaggio con la pancia con l'udito e con
il cuore sia restando a tavola
ascoltando buona musica anche
semplicemente cucinando a casa
il mio è stato un esperimento che
appunto quest'anno ha provato a
raccogliere in un libro sono 100piatti
di assaggiare una volta della vita ma in
realtà è una compilation di 100 pillole
narrative
ognuna ha abbinato al gatto del cuore è
una canzone e per cercare di
indirizzarla mi sono orientato su tre
punti cardine la musicalità intrinseca
che sprigiona un alimento un cibo un
piatto mentre lo stiamo assaporando
la colonna sonora che ci portiamo nella
memoria e in qualche modo a lanciare
qualche momento organolettico niente
della nostra esistenza e infine
l'aspetto che più caro l'attitudine
l'abitudine melodica e sonora che ci
trasmette che ci propaga un fuoco o la
persona che entra così se nasci il pasto
quindi e darci questo atto d'amore
ecco solcando queste note nello
specifico del brano che ho scelto perché
intervento di oggi che brief eddie floyd
in video dopo tutti voi a trovare lo
spartito gastronomico che più vi dà a
beneficio che gp pianifica e lo faccio
facendo di respirare e assaggiando
incubo un dream it è un piatto che sono
stati pensati per l'occasione da due
realtà romare accusano molto molto
affezionato
il cocktail e grigi latina che troverete
dopo il buffet è un fake che si chiama
biosfera è stato fatto dai ragazzi del
cocktail bar freni e flessioni di roma
questo tecniche cerca di te ha pure di
trasformare un respiro un sorso cercato
di creare un legame tra l'ossigeno e i
quattro elementi primordiali presenti in
natura troverete un foglio illustrativo
vi consiglio di leggerlo perché è stato
fatto veramente al mestiere e poi
davanti a voi che queste questi
sacchetti c'è una focaccia di patate che
i ragazzi figli cuochi e ristoratori
malza mare più pieno e francesco hanno
in qualche modo i preziosi prestito con
un ingrediente fermentato che the fear e
che dona e le strutture uno sviluppo di
lievitazione delle consistenze evolutivo
a un prodotto così umile popolare come
la focaccia ecco parliamo quindi gli
esercizi culinari e di miscela di che
giocano sull'assenza sulla modulazione o
sulla presenza dell'ossigeno e che si
però in quel mio di regali ma insieme
alla musica la famosa boccata d'aria da
me tanto appoggiata quest'anno buona
degustazione è buono ascoltato chi vuoi
[Applauso]